what's your sense in general is there
something interesting you could say
about your view on Free Speech it seems
like one of those terms that's also over
overuse to mean a lot of different
things what does it mean to you if you
have a democratic style of governance
you are interesting people with one of
the most awesome and radical of
responsibilities and that's saying that
you're going to pick the people that are
going to make some of the hardest
decisions in all of human history if
you're going to trust people to vote
correctly you have to be able to trust
them to have open and honest dialogue
with each other whether that's Nazis or
KKK people or whoever talking you have
to believe that your people are going to
be able to rise above and make the
correct determinations when they hear
these types of speeches and if you're so
worried that somebody's going to hear a
certain political figure and they're
going to be completely radicalized
instantly then what that tells me is
that you don't have enough faith in
humans for democracy to be a viable
institution which is fine you can be
anti-democratic but you I don't think
you can be pro-democracy and anti-free
speech within reason yeah so what's the
within reason so I mean not can was like
child porn or something on Twitter where
people try to get you on that stuff or
like direct calls to violence are
probably not you shouldn't be speaking
out like we're gonna meet up tomorrow
and go bomb blah blah blah so do you
think it's okay to allow racism and
anti-Semitism and uh hate speech
hate speech Yes because that's can be
very broadly defined um I can understand
there being some basic rules of like no
slurs on like a platform that gets into
like acceptable forms of moderation or
like excessive harassment and bullying I
can understand
um but past that when the when the
moderation becomes ideological I get a
little bit nervous because you know for
for there's a whole other yeah there's
uh of course it's all a gray area but
when it feels like ideology has seeped
into the censorship not good yeah which
it's so fascinating to think especially
now that Elon bought Twitter how do you
engineer A system that
prevents ideology from seeping in and
nevertheless is able to
create a platform that has healthy
conversations because if you have one
guy who's just screaming nonsense
non-stop it it has this effect where the
quiet voices at the back of the room are
silenced yeah so like that that's what
you usually don't talk about like if you
let one annoying loud person in that's
actually censoring the voice of a lot of
people that would like to speak but they
don't get a chance that's one of the
things especially around like trans
discourse I have to constantly do that
like reminder for my audiences so like
when I'm dealing with these types of
people on the internet a lot of them
might seem really crazy A lot of these
types of people might seem insane but
like in the real world outside of like
the crazy Twitter activist world like
the vast majority of people you're
meeting from LGBT communities are like
the coolest normalist people all they
want is to like write to live their life
and the way they want to and to be like
unobstructed and like yeah but people
will get this impression of like an
online activist like a vegan or LGBT
person or whatever and then they think
that every single person in real life is
like that and it's a really negative
stereotype